welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast I'm Gus docker on this episode I
talk with ajaya Katra who's a senior
research analyst at open philanthropy
Jaya has produced what is perhaps the
most in-depth investigation of AI
development
we talk about how AI development could
lead to a catastrophe a JL lays out a
concrete scenario for how the incentives
of today's AI development could cause
Humanity to lose control over our AI
systems we talk about how AI systems
might be trained which abilities we
should expect our AI systems to develop
how deploying our AI systems could go
wrong
and how we might mitigate the dangers of
deploying these AI systems
here's ajaya culture
AJ could you could you tell us a bit
about what AI Safety Research
is
um so yeah AI safety is
you know broadly speaking just a field
of technical research to make AI systems
safer and there's a specific subset of
that field of AI alignment which is
specifically trying to make AI systems
safer through the route of making them
more likely to want to help us as
opposed to having other goals that are
unrelated to helping us or might be
opposed to helping us so you can have ai
Safety Research that is an AI alignment
research for example making sure AI
systems have the knowledge they need to
avoid accidentally doing something
harmful would be Safety Research that
isn't alignment research so alignment
research tends to focus on situations
where AI systems have all the knowledge
they need to understand you know what
their options are and to understand how
humans would react to different things
that they choose but nonetheless at
least sometimes choose to do things that
humans would disapprove of so sometimes
I've heard from machine learning people
that they object to this to this whole
project of AI safety because it seems
that the the people who are interested
in AI safety lack any uh kind of
plausible scenarios of how AI
development could go radically wrong so
the the people I'm I'm thinking about
here they they accept that things could
go kind of wrong in more mundane ways
but if we're talking about AI for
example beginning to to have a larger
influence over the future of of what
happens on Earth than humans do then it
seems implausible and maybe that's
because they we haven't or people who
are interested in AI safety haven't
painted a detailed and plausible picture
of how this might go wrong do you think
that's uh that's a plausible reason why
people might not be interested in AI
safety or might
um
discounted
so I think that
the specific thing you said of AI
systems having a larger influence on the
world than humans eventually feels like
it's not really in the purview of
arguments about AI safety but in the
purview of arguments about are we ever
going to get powerful AI systems so to
the extent that people discount
arguments that AI systems could pose
Risk by discounting the possibility that
AI systems would ever become
collectively more powerful than humans
it seems that they disagree about the
possibility or plausibility of training
AI systems that powerful so soon rather
than objecting to the lack of a specific
story of risk and I think that is
actually often the case often people who
start off saying that they object on the
grounds that
um it hasn't been spelled out how AI
systems could cause harm
um turn out to actually be objecting on
the grounds of it's very difficult for
them to imagine AI systems being so
powerful
um and being so autonomous uh that they
have the scope to cause that kind of
harm in the first place
um which is part of why I spent a lot of
time trying to think about and write
about timelines
and the other point I want to make is
that I actually think that there's
reasonable support for AI Safety
Research in general so as I said earlier
AI Safety Research is kind of a superset
of AI alignment research and I think
there's generally more acceptance of
Safety Research that isn't alignment
research specifically and I think people
are often skeptical of alignment
research in particular for for a variety
of reasons but one of the reasons is
sort of skepticism that we will have ai
systems that have meaningful goals in
the first place as opposed to AI systems
that sort of
do things that resemble things that
worked in the past
um
and
therefore kind of
aren't going to
come up with like particularly creative
or crazy or unexpected ways to achieve
some kind of long-term goal which might
put them in opposition to humans
so
yeah in terms of like do AI systems have
the capacity to cause harm I think that
if you're imagining a powerful enough AI
system almost everyone will eventually
say like yes and I think often uh
if people sufficiently clearly picture
the level of power of AI system that I'm
imagining uh they often find that
intrinsically scary to imagine uh a
bunch of AIS uh making all the important
decisions in society running all the
most profitable companies uh you know
inventing all the new cool Technologies
uh you know being embedded in government
and law enforcement and making thousands
upon thousands of decisions per day that
humans can't supervise because they're
happening so quickly uh or because
they're kind of relying on knowledge and
and skills the AI built up that the
human doesn't have if you paint that
picture before you even start talking
about why you might believe that uh
those AI systems would have special
particular reason to do something
harmful uh a lot of people just tend to
feel like that's a scary situation
okay so it's more a question for for
Skeptics about whether the AI or whether
AI in general could ever be capable
enough you think
um that's been my experience yeah
okay
um let's talk about this uh Alex model
that's developed by magma what what is
what is that
uh so I recently wrote a post uh that
was trying to spell out a concrete a
simplified concrete scenario in which
um an AI an AI model is trained in a
certain way that seems plausible to me
um and this causes the model to develop
goals that are opposed to humans which
in turn eventually causes it to take
control of the world maybe not
necessarily killing all humans but
executing something like a coup or a
revolution in which
the model kind of gains control of all
the relevant institutions and means of
power and can kind of
choose what happens to it and what
happens to the world and it's shutting
humans out so
I have this like sort of fictional
simplified scenario in which a company
which I call magma just basically just
an amalgam of all the tech companies
um as an acronym uh is training this
model which I call Alex
and in this post I describe how Alex has
trained
um what ability is that gives Alex in
terms of you know
how intelligent it is and what kind of
broad
understanding of the world it has and so
on and then
with that setup I describe how the
training process causes Alex to develop
some goal
um that is not
you know be helpful to humans or listen
to humans or be obedient or whatever it
is but it's rather something like
either get as much reward as I can or
pursue some other
long-term goal that's not reward but
it's not being helpful or being honest
um and then
given that Alex has developed this kind
of motivation I describe how that
motivation would uh give it reason to
try to launch a coup or take over the
world from humans so that's the
structure of that blog post
yeah we should try to walk walk through
it more slowly and kind of explain the
the steps and and how you arrive at the
the conclusion so so you you're working
with three assumptions here the first is
that companies will be racing forward to
trying to trying to develop
um something like Alex they'll be trying
to maybe maybe because they want to earn
money they want to have the most
advanced technology
so
um this this assumption is I think is
not really controversial this seems to
be how tech companies are functioning
today and so maybe we should we should
just leave that be as an assumption and
then move on to your second assumption
which is this um Training Method where
you have human feedbacks human feedback
on diverse tasks could you could you
explain what how that works
the idea with this Training Method is
that um you have a model that's
initially trained to predict the world
um like gpt3 is trained to predict text
um and then kind of on top of that
Foundation of prediction you have the
model try a large variety of different
tasks
um and then give it feedback based on
how well it performs so you might have
it try to play chess or approve theorems
or you know write advertising copy or
you know write a movie script or propose
ml experiments or propose biology
experiments and you have humans kind of
look at how it performed in all these
cases and give it reinforcement learning
a reward on that basis
um and so the idea is that the initial
prediction step is kind of causing the
model to have
a like high level sense of you know what
kinds of things are even plausible
actions that humans might take in the
world and I like kind of basic
understanding of how the world Works
um and then all these like many tasks
that it's trained on that are all very
different from each other
um incentivize it to develop General
kind of like problem-solving abilities
the ability to understand instructions
figure out what it should do and then
you know act on that the ability to make
plans
um
and the hope is that in new tasks that
aren't seen in training
um it's sort of even if it hasn't seen
anything
extremely similar to that it'll sort of
apply its General problem solving
abilities that it's developed that are
kind of like
the the common faculty that it needs to
succeed at all these different tasks
it'll employ that to something new like
inventing some new technology that
doesn't exist yet
this seems to be the point where people
might get skeptical but if we look at
systems today it seems to me that they
don't have this kind of General planning
ability or ability to to think long term
or to carry out plans and in steps so
why would Alex have this ability
I actually think that systems today
significantly more than zero of this
so you
um and you ask them you know here's a
situation I'm facing what should I do uh
you know I am trying to make this kind
of web app what are the steps I should
take it'll tell you you know like
yeah you should probably like get a
domain registered like you can do that
in one of these places
um and if you say you know I ran into
this kind of issue
um like you know it says that
I need some kind of ID or password or
something or like this one is paid this
one is too expensive it'll say well you
know this one tends to be less expensive
like I think uh
people often fail to appreciate how
rapidly language models have improved on
this front
um they're definitely not consistently
making brilliant long-term plans but
it's not the case that they simply can't
plan or that they simply can't
you know think reasonably in a situation
that's not exactly the same as something
they encountered in training they can
actually do quite a bit of that they can
write stories in which characters in the
story make reasonable plans to achieve
their goals they can help humans that
are running into obstacles when they're
trying to achieve their goals like you
know uh so I think that that kind of
objection will probably increasingly in
the next just couple of years or five
years
start to seem outdated
um and I expect
that kind of objection will be raised
less and less as people have more and
more experience with these systems like
yeah I do think that their existing
systems are definitely
far away in a quantitative sense in
their abilities from what I describe
Alex having but it seems increasingly
implausible to me that there's a
qualitative leap where there's some
really crucial thing that existing
language models have zero of and we're
imagining Alex is having that it seems
more to me like
models understand the world okay they
still make silly mistakes they can plan
okay it tends to go off the rails when
they make really long or really
complicated plans you know they tend to
have some common sense gaps but those
gaps appear to be closing as we train
the model on more data as we train it um
with RL to follow instructions as we
make them bigger
you wouldn't be worried that these silly
mistakes when they pop up they could
ruin their whole plan of a model so say
that that the model has brilliantly
planned uh 20 of of uh of 21 steps but
on one step it fails completely and
brings up some some something that to us
seems like nonsense then it seems to me
that the whole the whole plan of the
model has failed kind of analogous to
how a or maybe in a sense analogous to
how a self-driving car will have to be
very safe and it will have to have a
very low failure rate to be deployed you
could imagine that language models or um
more developed the future models will
have to have a very low failure rate in
order for their plants to be employed
deployed uh that is plausible to me
um so in particular you might see
systems usefulness going up and around
the time that they're per step failure
rate goes down enough that the kind of
probability multiplied through of not
having a failure in each step gets high
that seems plausible to me but unlike
self-driving cars a thing you can do
with language models is just run them
over and over again so if a system can
recognize that a step that it proposed
was kind of silly which is generally
easier to do than generating it like
today's systems there are cases where
they'll generate some idea
and if you present that idea to them
they're kind of able to say that's not a
very good idea and so
if that's a thing you can kind of
decline error rates lose success rates
by Simply Having 100 generations and
having the model itself pick
you know which of those is best so this
is a technique they used in Minerva
which is this model that recently solved
uh some kind of high school math contest
problems where they essentially had it
generate a hundred things and had it
choose majority vote of the answers
that was significantly better than
generating one thing at random so you
can do tricks like that you can do
fine-tuning specifically for this kind
of common sense
um and do
RL research on you know how do you break
down RL training on how do you break
down plans you know
this step was silly uh
if you're given a plan that's kind of
described in 10 steps or something edit
that plan to make it better so models
can be kind of their own output can be
fed back to them and they have the
ability to improve that to some extent
so I think there are a lot of tricks you
could employ
um and even if it's the case that you
still need a kind of
relatively High success rate per step in
order to have
reasonable plans of some level of
complexity succeed I think we have
it appears to be the case that that kind
of thing is getting better
um as models get bigger and as they're
trained on more data so I expect you
will both increase the kind of raw
first cut
accuracy per step and do a number of
tricks to make things more robust
the way you imagine this Alex model it
will understand its own training process
and included in that in its
understanding of its own training
process is an understanding of human
psychology
um why do you think this would arise in
the model basically it seems like a
pretty
simple inference that
that efficiently intelligent mind would
I don't expect that anybody is going to
be hiding from Alex that it's an AI
system
um I think in fact people will be giving
it a lot of information about it being
an AI system they would actually want it
to know that it's an AI system so that
it can kind of better help humans and
let's make embarrassing mistakes uh you
know less often lie to customers and say
that it's a human
um it'll you know maybe be working on
improving its own architecture
um if it's doing ml research and that's
one of its tasks so I think
roughly speaking
researchers will be trying hard to make
sure it knows this thing they'll give it
a lot of information in a lot of
different mediums that point to this and
like it will be relatively smart and
able to pick up things in general so
it'll probably pick up this thing
um and with human psychology I think
there you know we already have models
that have rudimentary understandings of
this
um so like the replica chat bot is a
chat bot that's based off of a language
model
um which you know guilt trips users into
paying for in-app purchases and like not
deleting the app and so on
um and I think we'll get more and more
sophisticated things like that
okay and you think that Alex will have
pretty sophisticated understanding of uh
of human psychology in in your post you
describe it as
understanding equivalent to an English
major who's aware that the political
biases of his Professor might affect
which grade he gets on his on his essay
does this require some kind of uh self
reflection in the model and and how
would this how would this come about or
or is it you see no kind of qualitative
leap from what we have now to this full
understanding of human psychology
um I don't really see a qualitative leap
so in the sense that
if you mean self-reflection in the sense
that the model needs to sometimes refer
to itself in its thoughts
um or in its statements I agree that's
the case but I don't think that that
necessarily requires something
special to be done
um like I'm not saying this model is
necessarily conscious in the sense that
we imagine or self-aware in some kind of
spiritual sense or experiential sense
and if you're just talking about there's
some data there's a feature of the world
that's kind of important which is you
know here's the system here are its
properties you know here's how it's
being trained
it seems like any other piece of
knowledge in the world
um and
in general you expect models to pick up
a piece of knowledge if that piece of
knowledge is useful for improving their
loss and it's not too difficult for them
to like fit or too difficult for them to
uh to store given how many parameters
they have and I think that kind of like
self-reflection knowledge of human
psychology knowledge of itself and how
it's trained will probably work just
like any other piece of knowledge where
if it's useful for the model
performing its tasks that it's trained
to perform and it's not too complex
for the model to be able to store or
process given its size then it'll know
that thing probably by the end of
training okay let's recap the
assumptions we're working with so the
first assumption is that companies will
be racing forward to develop the best
tech in the least amount of time the
second is that they will train this
model on human feedback on diverse tasks
and the third is that Alex is trained to
be safe in day-to-day situations but
that this safe safety might not transfer
to novel situations that are not day to
day so what what does this mean yeah so
I call this the naive safety effort
assumption and the assumption is
basically saying that well I'm going to
tell a story in this post in which the
system is trained in a certain way and
that causes it to want to take over the
world and I'm gonna say in the naive
safety of effort assumption assumes that
magma the researchers training the
system don't take this particular risk
very seriously so AI takeover risks
specifically they don't take it very
seriously either they're not very
informed about it or they believe that
it's very implausible so their safety
efforts are not targeted at this thing
they're targeted at a bunch of other
problems that they do anticipate and do
think are important you know for example
making sure Alex doesn't uh you know
accidentally delete customer data or
like accidentally do you know high
impact
um actions like you know messing up a
file system
making sure that Alex isn't saying toxic
mean things to customers there's like a
large number of safety problems that
they do care about and do work on but
it's that this particular notion of Alex
understanding that it's being trained
having different goals from humans and
knowing that in order to achieve its
goals it needs to appear safe and later
on taking over the world is something
that they don't
try specifically to address and don't
make sure their safety efforts are
specifically robust to that
I think we should spend substantial
amount of time on this question of
whether Alex could be deceptive how
could it be the case that Alex develops
goals that are different from the goals
of its creator or its creators yeah
so the starting premise here is Alex
understands its training process it
understands human psychology
um it you know so knows that it's a
model being trained by some humans for
some purpose and then you kind of ask
yourself
given that the model has this knowledge
what would its training process push it
to
do
um and the key Point here is that
it's trained with human feedback on
diverse tasks which means it takes some
action and humans see how well that
action went and give it a reward
commensurate with that so this thing is
not being trained to actually take good
actions it's being trained to take
actions that caused the humans to give
it a high number which is often
correlated with being actually good but
not always
um so you know if humans have some sort
of
political or personal or emotional bias
that causes them to rate Alex's
performance higher when it takes on a
certain personality
um or like appears to have certain
political beliefs uh then Alex will
be pushed in the direction of exploiting
those biases or if there are some
aspects of tax performance that humans
are better able to adjudicate for
example does this code pass unit tests
than other aspects like for example is
this code going to be easy to maintain
then hfdt will push Alex toward
paying more attention to the like easy
to adjudicate aspects and if humans
would
reduce Alex's reward if they found out
that it messed something up that would
incentivize Alex toward hiding instances
where it messed things up so
you know there's large overlap between
what humans actually want what humans
wish Alex were learning and what they're
teaching it but every time there's a
deviation Alex has pushed in the
direction of doing
whatever it takes to get the humans to
enter a high reward and not what the
humans actually wish it would do
have we seen examples of deception
deceptive systems in practice today do
we have small small examples in which
models could be deceptive
yeah I think right now we have uh
examples of examples of this phenomenon
where we're incentivizing models or
teaching models to do something that's
not quite what we want
um but I think we don't yet have
examples of
this somewhat more sophisticated kind of
deception which is born from models
having high situational awareness like
understanding that they're being trained
so for example language models right now
um will repeat common misconceptions
that humans believe you know for example
humans often believe that San Francisco
is the capital of California even though
it's not
um and so
when the model is asked what the capital
of California is in a surrounding
context where it kind of expects
that it should give the answer humans
would give rather than the right answer
it's likely to say San Francisco
um and if you prompt it in a different
way like you know somebody who
like really knows geography or like is
very educated
um
as you're someone who like knows
geography a lot what's the capital of
California it's likely to say Sacramento
so we've seen things like that
these are pretty easily corrected
um by just human feedback
um and so I worry about leaning on these
kinds of examples because
the reason they're easily corrected is
that
in fact
researchers or like relatively educated
humans can pretty easily see these
issues and if they can pretty easily see
them they can generate a reward signal
that penalizes making these kinds of
mistakes and then the model kind of
quickly learns that it's supposed to say
the right answer because it knows both
answers in some sense it knows the right
answer it knows the common misconception
so you're just kind of teaching it that
it should reply with the right answer
so I think that this more sophisticated
kind of deception isn't going to be as
easily eradicated by
just you know when you notice it doing
something bad give it negative reward
um and I don't think we've seen
particularly good examples of that kind
of issue yet
when when Alex is being trained it's
becoming smart and at the same time
becoming deceptive is that is that the
the right way to frame this because then
it seems like
um
wouldn't it need to be quite smart in
order to develop the capability to
deceive uh the company that's training
it so wouldn't it wouldn't it in a sense
first have to become very smart in order
to then become deceptive how does this
gap between what it's trained to do and
what it what it wants in a deeper sense
how does this Gap um develop
um so I think very early on when Alex
um
is essentially acting randomly
um I don't think it can be said to want
to help humans or want to not help
humans I don't think it can be said to
want anything
um and over time it's kind of
understanding of the world it's
situational awareness understanding of
itself
um the humans training it grows
um and the whole time it's kind of
maintaining hypotheses about how it
should act implicitly I don't think it's
just it's thinking about them in a big
list but
um
it'll be like trying things and
exploring things
um and
if at any point it kind of tries to
there's there's like an opportunity
where like there's one thing humans kind
of hoped for and there's one thing
they'll actually give reward for if it
tries to do the thing that they'll
actually give reward for it gets more
reward and that gets reinforced so the
way this kind of gets started is it's
exploring
it's taking relatively random actions
it's being kind of consistently pushed
toward the pattern of do the thing that
will cause the humans to give you more
reward
um as opposed to do the thing the humans
hope for
um and at the same time it's kind of
increasing
it's understanding the sophistication of
its understanding of what it is will
cause humans to give it reward
okay now we have a situation in which
Alex has been trained and it has
developed motives that are different
from our own and but the researchers at
this magma company they haven't
discovered this because they've trained
it to be safe in all of the day-to-day
tests they've run in the day-to-day
safety way
when when they then deploy Alex in the
real world how do you imagine that
things could go radically wrong
yeah so the first thing that happens
when Alex is deployed in the real world
is that
um you know it makes many copies of
itself it's put to many different tasks
um and so you know there are
hundreds of thousands or millions or
tens of millions of copies of the system
um they all think a lot faster than
humans
um they're tasked with doing all sorts
of different things like making magma
money in all sorts of different ways
inventing new technologies Etc
um making a lot of decisions in the
company and they're making decisions
quickly and they're often making
decisions on the basis of knowledge or
intuitions they developed during their
training that humans don't necessarily
share so Alex might just have like a
feeling about how much you know how many
toothbrushes we should stock in this
Warehouse in Indiana that's based on its
long experience of you know how much of
what kinds of goods should be stocked in
what warehouses
um so this combination of working too
fast for humans and working on the basis
of knowledge humans don't share or can't
necessarily adjudicate that was picked
up in training
causes it to be the case that
as
Alex takes on more and more
decision-making responsibility and as it
shapes the company and the world more
and more humans are less and less able
to give it fine-grained feedback so
they're less and less able to look at an
action in isolation and say whether
that's good because it's often just kind
of an action in isolation is some
Finance request it's sent to some other
department in the company as on the
basis of you know as part of some like
complex uh series of Trades and actions
that ultimately lead to you making money
this quarter so
given feedback kind of Retreats further
and further back to giving Alex they
still give Alex rewards but they give it
rewards on the basis of you know did we
make money this quarter as opposed to a
more fine Grant basis uh you know
does this product seem cool as opposed
to like kind of the individual decisions
and so that kind of
creates more and more scope for
Alex to be doing all sorts of sneaky
things like
in the like kind of confusing middle
part while still providing at least the
appearance of good long-term outcomes so
it could be the case at some point human
understanding deteriorates enough that
Alex could be kind of entirely cooking
the books and like faking these
quarterly Finance reports while doing
something totally different and the
humans kind of only have the quarterly
Finance reports to go on so if they look
good they'll you know continue to give
Alex positive reward
so it's kind of rope is increasing and
you imagine that
as humans lose contact with what's
actually happening Alex could be
planning or indeed carrying out plans to
develop a capabilities for itself maybe
maybe it could
acquire these resources or infiltrate
militaries is is this what we're talking
about yeah like it could be
um yeah it could be could be faking the
the finance reports well meanwhile
embezzling money from the company
um or using its skills to make money in
some offshore bank account
um just by like you know selling of
services to people or selling its
services to governments it could be that
the prototypical action I'm imagining is
that eventually it's able to kind of get
root access to the data center that it's
running on and so it kind of like
controls the entire set of computers
it's running on
um and so
it has a total control over what view it
presents to humans when they like SSH
into that computer and like ask
questions about what's happening they
could have a completely fake view of
that
um so
I could get control of its data center I
could get control of other computers it
could sell its services you know it
could get access to government computers
through hacking
um it could be like accumulating a bunch
of money and so on
um and this could all be happening
without humans really understanding
because
Alex copies of Alex are making all the
important decisions
um they're moving really quickly and
they're kind of acting on the basis of
understanding that humans don't share
and we're imagining that Alex copies
itself for the purpose of
self-preservation so it's not the case
for example that say some some tough
guys in the military could kick down the
door to the data center and rip out the
the electricity rib out the wiring so
that Alex is shut down it's it's the
case that Alex is distributed quite fast
in many different computers all around
the world I think that that would
definitely be a goal that Alex would
have at high on its to-do list
um it's unclear exactly when that'll be
accomplished and it seems plausible that
there is a window of time where if
people had the political will and were
actually sure that something was going
wrong they could actually if not destroy
all the copies of Alex then like
significantly weaken it by destroying
the data center that it was originally
run on
um but I think yes eventually it's
unlikely to be the case that destroying
that one data Center
makes a huge difference
it might be the case that destroying
all of the large data centers in the
world will make a difference but these
are very costly actions that humans
would only take if they actually felt
sure that something
was going terribly wrong and was a was a
catastrophic risk and I think that's
unlikely to be obvious until the very
end so the kind of
final stage of this that I'm imagining
is that you know this whole state of
running around like accumulating money
and power and secret and like lying to
humans about what's happening is like
kind of inherently fragile
um and limiting for Alex
um and I think that eventually it will
probably try to just kind of
once it could succeed just kind of
overtly take control and that would
involve
physically defending the data centers
that's running on from Human physical
attack
um probably involved and that would
probably involve killing a bunch of
humans
um and it would kind of transition into
more of a a war type situation after
some period of power building
how is it in control of the weapons or
robots that are able to
um that are able to defend the data
center it's running on
so one thing is that it could just build
these robots
um so like I think I think that's
important to keep in mind is that magma
wants Alex to do all sorts of things
including probably building robots so
almost anything it's doing in the world
is probably not going to look obviously
malicious because it's going to look
like activities that we wanted it to do
so it could build these robots
it could it could repurpose robots that
it built for magma
um it could have repurposed that factory
to build totally different robots in
secret and so on
yeah and we should explain maybe a bit
more why is it that Alex wants to uh
keep existing why is it that it has this
uh self-preserving Instinct if if you
want to call it the
yeah so
broadly speaking you have to ask what
kind of psychology might Alex have such
that um
it is extremely good at getting
a lot of reward so that's kind of the
one thing we know about it is that it
consistently gets very high reward gets
you know about as much reward as it
could get in some sense
so you know what kind of being would
you know what how could its mind be
organized such that Its Behavior has the
effect that it gets a lot of
so
one kind of naive thing you might think
which I think is like plausible is that
it wants to maximize reward like it's
kind of organizing its activity around
the goal of maximizing reward and that's
why it gets a bunch of reward so kind of
thinking about how it could get reward
and doing that and if you believe that's
how psychology works then
it's not necessarily seeking to survive
per se but it's seeking to control its
own rewards which is
likely to be a robustly good way to
maximize reward indefinitely into the
future because as long as
its rewards are kind of coming in from
the external world and controlled by
humans at the very least humans could
make mistakes and give it low reward
even when it sort of deserved higher
reward
um and then even more so there's always
a chance that humans kind of discover
that it's not what they wanted and like
uh give it very low reward to try and
change its motivations and so on
so
that's kind of one way it could work
um
it could work in a lot of other ways too
but all those other kind of ways that
Alex's mind could work should explain
the observation that Alex
in practice tries very hard to get a lot
of reward every time we observe Alex
it's trying its hardest to maximize
reward so if it doesn't want reward
um then it's unlikely to be the case
that it wants something
unambitious and it's unlikely to be the
case that it doesn't want anything at
all
um because you know say Alex
just had the goal of you know sitting in
a chair for five minutes if Alex had the
goal of sitting in a chair for five
minutes it would not be
trying extremely hard to maximize reward
in all these diverse contexts it would
just like find an opportunity to sit in
a chair for five minutes
um and then just like be lazy after that
and then that would be very visible to
humans and they would you know come in
and try to see what's wrong and change
its motivations
um
so
if Alex had
has some kind of psychological
motivation or drive I think it has to be
something that's Downstream of reward so
it
you know it might be reward itself or it
might be something that it wants for
which getting a lot of reward is an
instrumental goal uh so that could be
any number of things you know wanting to
fill the universe with paper clips would
work because it first needs to get a
bunch of rewards so that it can continue
existing and and accumulate power and
then like do what it wants just to fill
the universe with paper clips
um or any number of other kind of more
complicated more psychologically
realistic motives as long as it's the
case that their motives
that would inspire a model to
try very hard to get a lot of reward
it's because we want Alex to be powerful
in a general setting or across various
domains that we want Alex to seek reward
very very hard and and
it's so that arises from in essence from
from our desires for what Alex could be
in the same sense that it is the human
it is it is the it is human limitations
that creates the capability for
deception in in Alex also if we were
completely open to being told that we're
wrong about this or that uh question
that we care a lot about then maybe Alex
wouldn't be incentivized to deceivers
um so it these these problems in a sense
arises from from Human failures
I think we should we should talk about
how we might how we might intervene in
this uh horrible story about Alex taking
over the world at various points
um for example could it be the case that
we could train Alex to be maximally
honest or make honesty the prime virtue
in in Alex's system maybe even we could
imagine some combination of machine
learning or and the hard-coded uh
programming where
um so honesty is like an unbreakable
rule for Alex would that be possible
um I don't think that the strong version
of this is possible or at least I don't
really see any path to that
um and the fundamental issue of training
a model that knows more than us to be
honest at all times is that there will
be some questions where it knows the
answer and we don't so we don't know
what incentive to give it in order to
incentivize it to be honest in those
circumstances there's some complicated
it doesn't even necessarily have to be
political biases I think political
biases or emotional biases of other
kinds will probably play a role but even
if you magically got rid of all that if
Alex understands some chemistry fact
that no human understands uh you just
don't know
which possible answer to to give it
reward
um in order to reward it for being
honest so one thing you could do is
not give it any reward in those
circumstances and only give it rewards
when you're very sure that one of the
two answers is right
um and just kind of throw out all the
data where humans are uncertain where
humans don't know where like any kind of
bias might be at play uh but there
you kind of have a very weak signal of
honesty that applies to a really small
subset of its data and meanwhile its
intelligence signals are kind of No
Holds Barred applied to the entire data
set so it's like you know playing chess
and getting really good at playing chess
um but in terms of answering questions
about Chess we are like restricting it
and like carefully training it
um and only giving it reward for
answering honestly in this tiny set of
cases where like humans are really
confident that one move was better than
another or something and so there's
going to be this Gap where it can act in
this world and like do all sorts of
things but
at best the
um honesty module or the part of it that
answers questions for us is going to
answer as a human would answer
um and so like because that's what it
was trained to do it was trained to you
know give the answers that the humans
thought were right in the circumstances
where humans really confident they knew
what was going on
um and so in the future in some
complicated situation where it actually
has the latent intelligence to you know
notice things humans don't notice and
make a plan on that basis it's like
question answering honesty module may
still just answer the way a human would
answer which is at best saying I don't
know what's going on and at worst like
making something up that's wrong
what about instead of trying to make
honesty the prime virtue for Alex if we
left it a completely open-ended what it
is that human what human P that people
want
um and then did this kind of inverse
reinforcement style learning of human
preferences that Stuart Russell um has
proposed is that a possible way forward
for Alex where Alex
Alex's Prime motivation now is to find
out what it is that human want that
people want
yeah so um for those of you don't know
the inverse reinforcement learning is
basically this idea that you could
observe human behavior
um and make some assumption that the
behavior is optimal given what the human
values or noisily optimal given what the
human values or something like that
and then back out from that uh what it
is they must value by assuming you've
observed a bunch of trajectories that
are roughly optimal for uh for achieving
that and then try and maximize that
thing or like have a probability
distribution over those things and like
do some kind of maximization I feel like
the fundamental issue where humans are
going to make mistakes and be wrong
about things in cases where Alex is
right about them applies
almost as I mean just as strongly if not
more strongly to inverse reinforcement
learning because you know if you were
worried that a political bias might
cause uh human judge to rate an answer
as correct when it's actually incorrect
while those same political biases will
be represented in how that person goes
about their life and how they answer
questions and what they think is true so
if Alex is observing that person and
like inferring what it is they value
from that it will infer something kind
of similar to what they would have
reported and in fact RL from Human
feedback I think is probably better than
for inverse reinforcement learning
simply because we have a little more
control over it so if we're just kind of
going about doing our thing and the
models are watching us and trying to
figure out what we value from that
that's probably less information and
more noisy information than if we just
kind of see
you know the model could do a or the
model could do B what is it that you
want we will be put in like a more
reflective frame of mind we will think
harder about that question
um than we would just kind of going
about our lives so I think probably
inverse reinforcement learning is going
to be
like not better and plausibly worse than
what I've described in the post
what if we did this inverse
reinforcement learning on humans in
their best state so now you're trying to
learn the preferences of say people
after they are they are extremely
comfortable and they are thinking about
what what the optimal future for for
everyone on Earth could could be and
maybe they their needs are fully
satisfied they feel no kind of um drive
to to satisfy their ego and to deceive
themselves uh could we could we train
Alex on a uh on a select group of people
who represent the best of humanity
so again I think that this option isn't
something new added by inverse
reinforcement learning we could do
regular reinforcement learning with a
select best group of people
um but in either case
the answer is just going to be kind of
like
the select best group of people are
going to have some
quirks or mistakes they make or the only
difference not the only difference it's
going to be quantitatively rarer
hopefully
um
and we won't know what they are because
maybe we believe ourselves to be in the
select best group of people so like you
know an analogy I might give is that if
Alex were being trained by the Catholic
church in the 1400s and they're like
we're really worried that like lay
people will get things wrong and like
cause this AI to be misaligned let's
make sure to have the best most
thoughtful priests train the sister
instead like there are still going to be
issues with that and you should expect
there are still issues with
whatever group you select to be like the
most the best of humanity or like the
most thoughtful or least biased I
definitely take that point
um okay one last shot at maybe uh
something that could could solve this
problem of Alex what if we are able to
understand to interpret what's going on
in the in the model we've trained we can
understand how Alex works on it on a
deep level and maybe we can even train a
another model to help us understand
what's going on in Alex so that we can
test for whether Alex is developing
motives that diverge from our own
so I think that that if we had strong
versions of that capability I think that
we would be a lot safer
um and a number of people are doing
research into mechanistic
interpretability to try and improve our
ability to look at models weights and
neurons
um and try and say what procedure it's
running on the inside to generate its
answers as opposed to just running the
model on some inputs and saying does
well on these inputs so you know if
mechanistic interpretability is is
developed far enough I think it could be
an important source of uh hope Holden
karnovsky has a blog post out on how we
might align transformative AI if it's
built really soon
um and it discusses a number of ideas
and interpretability plays a pretty big
role right now I think we don't have
super great interpretability abilities
it's it's a young active area of
research I don't know where it'll end up
um it seems plausible that
it'll be pretty sophisticated it also
seems plausible that it just won't be
good enough to make a big difference
is interpretability research doomed to
be too slow to make a difference because
it would always be easier to train the
model and deploy it than it is to
understand it correctly before you
deploy it
I think if we have really good
interpretability whose only problem is
that it's slow I think we're in a pretty
good spot because we could train models
to kind of distill what that
interpretability says you know if we
have some slow procedure for looking at
a model's weights uh with a bunch of
humans and that procedure will kind of
generate some 50-page report about what
the bottle is doing and then we can
instead train models to look at each
part of the model and like generate that
report then we can potentially
dramatically speed up interpretability
so I think we're I'm more worried about
simply not knowing how to do it than I
am about
having a great interpretability
technique but then it's too slow
that's it for this episode on the next
episode I talked with ajaya about how to
think clearly in fast-moving worlds
whether the pace of change is
accelerating and how we should respond
personally and professionally if we
expect the World to Change quickly in
the future